I like hearing Raven's around when I'm
hunting
as we know that the game is over too
God
yeah
that's how you pray to the Raven great
great grandma Elder taught me and told
Grandma I have bad luck I can't get
moose she don't pray to the Raven so I
pray to the raving I got to move stuff
from that
[Music]
I feel really good about my girl's
future 10 15 years from now they're
going to have their own families and
they're going to be bringing their kids
out and showing them different lands
landmarks Hills and Creek
it's just really talk she can't tell
[Music]
ah
oh he's right there
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
trying to get this bull to walk towards
us
it's not an everyday opportunity out
here to shoot a moose
it'll feed a lot of people
[Music]
most of times when I call out moose like
this they'll come directly to the call
so I'm not sure if he's seen us maybe he
spotted us up here on this little Hill
it's pretty promising you should
have been up there on that engine the
future
he must keep his cow and his back leg
back
foreign
just like he's protecting his car
definitely need a lot of patience to be
successful in this country
you think we should come back to this
Lake yeah it seems pretty promising
oh yeah
[Music]
thank you